there's no denying that ballerin is a
good looking game but visually things
have been getting a bit too cluttered
now that's not good for existing players
but with the rate that they're releasing
new characters and abilities it might
turn off new players as well but is this
all a part of Riot's bigger plan
[Music]
Valor has had a pretty interesting week
on top of the ongoing concerns
surrounding the state of rank play and
the fact that they released an 80 skin
bundle that looks like the default CS go
Skins they also dropped a pretty
controversial UI update the update was
supposed to ease some of the visual
clutter that has accumulated over the
last few years of agent releases but by
the community reaction it seems it had
the opposite effect I think there
honestly could have been a number of
ways to deal with this uh
problem uh that they have this task that
Ryan had
um because I understand it's you know
it's a tricky thing like you know how
you differentiate between like 10
different abilities right
but
certainly the one that they chose was
not the right way but the conversation
around valorance over stimulation is not
a new one people have been long
complaining about the amount of crap
they have to shoot on screen and things
hit an entirely new level once Valerian
started releasing more agents with
flashes
[Applause]
two two
unfortunately it only ever got worse as
Rye continued to release more characters
with walls smokes and traps rounds
became crowded with abilities and it
eventually led to some cursed screen
grabs like this this and this at times
valorant feels like a chaotic mess
that's a parody of a game where you're
shooting more abilities than you are
other people whether you're playing or
watching it can feel like a complete
cluster especially now with the
meta-serving smoke and wall agents
having two vipers and Two Harbors on a
map can lead to situations that are
confusing for the audience particularly
if they're new to the game
ah decision killed elbow the game has
too much utility the game is utility
confessed it's insane there's flying
drones animals the zoo [__] ghosts
[__] the poison walls [__] when
is it ever [__] stop this [__] man
and that's where we get to the Crux of
the issue here this might be harming
valorin's accessibility in the long run
like I've said on the show in the past
what Valor did very well was make attack
shooter that was more accessible than
anything else on the market but the more
characters and abilities they add the
more the game gets pushed in the
opposite direction CS go was always the
game that was considered to have a
tougher barrier for entry but the thing
is everyone in that game has the same
utility so you know what to expect I
mean sure you can still get flashed a
billion times in CS go but you don't
have to worry about a [__] dog
jumping around the corner took a survey
for a riot and it was like um they're
like one of the things was like visual
noise and I was just like
an extreme noise I can't see what's
going on my screen at any point in time
if more than two agents are doing
utility I just I'm like I feel like I'm
blind you know what I mean the issue is
that Riot and much of its fan base sees
new agents and abilities as a natural
progression for the game and that's
exactly what we've seen with their other
game League of Legends they now have 163
Champions and I can be very intimidating
for new players but existing players are
accustomed to it by now and probably see
it as a Hallmark of the game being
healthy and continuing to grow the
question is what do they do with
valorant they're obviously not going to
get rid of any other characters and the
updates to the UI didn't help so how can
they solve the issue of visual clutter
one option is a beginner's queue that
has a limited amount of Agents if there
was a cue for beginners that had the
basic agents it might help them get
acclimatized to the game before they're
ready to experience more of course they
can also bring in a rotating pool of
active duty agents so every time a new
agent is brought in one is taken out to
get tweaked on and that way new players
don't have to to learn everything all at
once but this would likely piss off a
lot of the existing player base who have
strong attachments to a certain agent or
two and they don't want to see them
locked away from competitive play for
months or weeks at a time okay so what
if Valerian tries pick and bans just
like in league and Siege both teams get
to ban a certain amount of Agents from
being played in a match now although
this is pretty ubiquitous in other games
and players have already been asking for
pick bands on maps this might lead to
the same problem where people are upset
that they can't play their favorite
agents the only other solution I can
think of is one that's very
controversial and comes with its own set
of hurdles but I think it is plausible
I'm talking about roll cue for those
that don't know valran is far from the
first game to have a problem with visual
clutter in fact people have often made
the joke that Valerian is actually
getting the OverWatch treatment on top
of suffering from their own issues with
visual clutter certain roles were
completely unbalanced and it led to some
brutal metas the game became miserable
to play and to solve the problem
blizzard introduced 222 and roll Q this
just meant that in a game you could only
have two of each hero class so if you
wanted to play a tank for example you
would have to specifically queue for it
in matchmaking the idea and valorant
would kind of be the same for example
let's say you can only have one wall
agent in a map you would have to
specifically queue for that before the
game now on top of being very
controversial there's some things that
hold the game back from even making this
possible
agents just do too Goddamn much if you
limit the match to only having one aging
with smokes and one agent with walls you
basically get rid of like half the
[__] cast because right decided that
every agent can do everything and the
classes don't actually mean anything in
my opinion the only solution is to
straight up rework the entire class
system and get rid of certain abilities
from certain characters but I don't
think Ryan's going to be too open to
that idea the question is what Solutions
are they open to they said in the past
that they would pump the brakes on
characters with unique abilities but
with the recent release of Gekko that
seems like it's gone out the window but
if that idea is already squashed are
they going to introduce anything to help
curb the visual clutter problem well
maybe not because you have to think
about what Riot's motivations here are
new agents and new abilities however
visually confusing keep people playing
and if they're playing they're likely
buying shiny new gun skins and even
bigger than that Riot's goal is to build
and maintain as strong of an IP as
possible think of the success of Arcane
for League of Legends and they've
already done a very good job of valoran
so far by release releasing flashy
agents that people can connect to and
build fandoms around so I doubt they're
going to slow down anytime soon bumping
up the price of abilities again you know
to uh like
kind of like make it like a little bit
harder to just ability spam but I think
that like you know showing it again so
that it's actually like
really you gotta be like really really
like you have to think really hard about
like oh do I actually want to use this
utility right right now and I mean like
it's actually worth this util because
right now it's still at the point where
it's just like all right let's just
throw everything into the site look
there is a lot for them to balance here
Wright needs to think about their own
business model as well as the needs of
new and existing players it's not easy
and even the solutions we've talked
about come with their own set of
problems but something has to be done
ride has made an amazing game here but
for God's sakes make it a bit easier on
the eyes please when CS go first
launched the molotov was like a big
contentious issue eventually people just
got used to it and we're kind of seeing
it again with like the smoke grenades in
CS2 because like they're Dynamic now and
you can shoot through them and blow them
up it's cool but like Nico for example
he's like super against it and he's like
oh yeah they're gonna get rid of this
which is insane to think because they've
spent so much money working on it that
like they're just gonna get rid of it
because Nico asked them to but the thing
is it's like people get used to those
things in CS even though they're pretty
apprehensive to anything visually
changing but with Valerian it's just
like there's no stop in it